gentlemen good evening welcome
have any of you ever actually spent a
day in a proper restaurant
no no no no never never [ __ ] me
please do not [ __ ] let me down yeah
let's get cooking yeah let's go thank
you
how's everybody so far so good so fast
yeah is the wine flowing yes starting
yes just nothing
okay one order four covers table three
four salad red mullet four saddle of
lamp
four summer pudding yes chef thank you
nigel fourth salad away table three how
long
uh give me a time seven minute chef
the start is a simple salad of red
mullet the brigade's been shown how to
make it
but to ensure they know what they're
doing i'm going to run through it one
more time
now watch hot pan potatoes are coloring
nicely yeah
yeah seasoning on the fish red mullet in
this takes literally seconds to cook
watch
the red mullet's nearly half cut you can
see it there it just sealed on the
bottom nothing more
but then watch you take them out
nice and gently okay watch
the dressing's a mixture of anchovies
garlic olive oil white wine vinegar
and tarragon red molly on
red mullet on a little bit of salad in
there
enough for three and then drip a little
bit nice and gently
pass the video down please gently watch
five covers chef
yeah hey i want it all nice now make me
[ __ ] two more of them on your own
yeah sure
nigel kevin's not too much salt on there
yes
what's in the dressing anchovies what
are they they're salty be careful
lawson yeah i think that fish is burnt
yeah i can see it from here turn it over
journey
turn it over quickly oh my god
so do it again let me ask you a question
would you eat it no i'll start did you
pay for it
no i'll pay i'll do it again the brigade
have got to get it right because i've
told the diners if they're not happy
they don't have to pay
they may be cooking but it's my
reputation on the line
my name's nigel i'm a good cook i'm a
big lover of
greek and portuguese food i think i'll
be able to hack it in gordon's kitchen
he's a big man with a big personality
but so am i
my name's robert jones this is my
signature dish and it's an award-winning
long boat of lamb to accompany that i
use an onion and garlic potato gratin
and some roasted mediterranean
vegetables
my name is kevin the largest number of
people i've cooked for is
probably about 10 people in one city so
to go into gordon's kitchen and cook for
50
it's gonna be a big challenge my name's
lawson
my dish is a roast beef dinner a nice
thick gravy
over the top with a nice big yorkshire
pudding we believe
gordon ramsay is one of the best chefs
in the country we know
that we're the best butchers in the
country we're entering into that kitchen
to be the best of the series that's our
own
awesome yes you'll doing me three salad
a red mullet
you've got four bits in there three twos
are what
you got four in there can i do four for
now no
so you want me to serve two at the table
and leave one on their own
come on [ __ ] hell guys listen listen
you're just rushing calm down
you're okay you can do this you just
can't right all night completely off the
edge you've got enough time
service please think about what you're
doing concentrate one table each yes
robert yeah it's not a race it's about
perfection okay this is not a [ __ ]
bang
out okay and hope for the best now we
put the food up
are you happy with that yeah you are yes
you are yes
come on yes i am good so you should be
[ __ ] off
kathy burke please yes
nigel who spilled that hold on stop stop
stop what's going on
the uh oh come on
come on guys you're gonna send us all on
[ __ ] fire watch out
watch out take the oil off the stove
quickly oh
[ __ ] me what are you doing awesome just
for five minutes
go and pick some [ __ ] strawberries
get out the back and [ __ ] pick some
strawberries
i think gordon is right i did panic
i was trying to do everything too
quickly too fast i'll have to calm down
and do things slower three minutes chef
look at that yeah but the first ones are
immaculate yeah
and that's probably that's perhaps the
worst [ __ ] [ __ ] you've cooked so far
in here
robert you can't be happy with that i
thought it would have played the quran
you can't be happy with that yeah
honestly no chef because you know what
the last three tables have been perfect
that's [ __ ] okay chef and then what do
you think of me if i let you send that
you're gonna think i'm alright [ __ ]
[ __ ]
it's an hour and a half since the diner
sat down and the last starters are only
just going out
it's bell's been getting me going anyway
to be honest
and what i really want to do is just
pick it up each other
but i've got a little bit to call
themselves
it's really sort of succulent light i
mean like a nice light flake if they
should it was cooked just right
gentlemen how are you very welcome
what's a matter with your starters
it's a very subtle flavor slightly sweet
a nice crispy skin
you're clearly not paying for that are
you no i'll make sure you pay for your
main course trust me
i don't think so i don't hi think so
right nice to see you very nice good to
see you
now i can't believe you're a [ __ ]
vegetarian that's not true is it
well no i'm not a vegetarian because i
eat fish okay so not
but i don't eat meat right i've been
eating meat for 24 years having a little
conversion later
no would you never eat meat again no i
have tried
but i don't think my stomach can handle
it anymore would you like to sleep with
me behind the scenes have a nice
lovely pink steak the most amazing
sirloin i'll get around the back and
chop
some meat where you'd call them no well
you especially i'm going to do the most
amazing
but don't tell the other [ __ ] i don't
want it okay special treatment very nice
good to see you see you later you don't
like risotto
not really oh [ __ ]
when you're a veggie that's all you get
given is risotto but people's houses for
dinner runs
yeah no but i will try because you're
cooking it
if you're unsure about the risotto yes
no no no no no no i've got an
amazing thing to tell you wild mushrooms
see you later
jean-baptiste how many customers are
paying for their starter
34 34 16 are not paying for the starter
34 are paying for the staffer
why not for the other 16. the main
reason is blend
plant yeah the fact that they had to
wait [ __ ] 90 minutes couldn't have
helped you know that's all
well i mean you go to a restaurant you
sat there an hour later you haven't got
your [ __ ] starter it spawns a taste
like you said
there may be 16 customers out there
refusing to pay for the [ __ ] starter
but i want 50 customers wanting to pay
for their land
so lawson yeah get a grip because right
now
it's me plus four butchers that's
starting to look a little bit [ __ ]
silly
concentrate and don't send it unless
we're [ __ ] happy we're already pissed
off 16 customers
bring it back next on the menu a
succulent stuffed saddle of lamb
angela griffin gets hot in the kitchen
in the recipe challenge i think you're
up last night practicing until [ __ ]
midnight i was practicing something but
it certainly wasn't cooking
and will the butchers finally crack
gentlemen
we've only served five tables so get a
grip
okay wakey wakey and lawson make some
ground up do something for me
welcome back to the f word now in a few
weeks time i'm going to be cooking roast
pork and i've started preparing the
ingredients already
before i do anything radical i'm
traveling to the river cottage in dorset
to talk to hugh furley whittingstall
about growing my own special ingredient
to be served in the f-word restaurant
pork
[Music]
hello girls come on are they all female
these ones actually two girls and a boy
two girls on the point have you named
the
polite
no i haven't named these i don't name
the piglets who aren't going to be
around for too long
god they run to you oh yeah well they
want their breakfast
what sort of pigs are you thinking of
getting i mean i'm a big fan of these
saddlebacks but yeah and that's a
popular local breed
but um we're looking at a rare breed
yeah so it's not essential to keep these
rare breeds alive yeah
some near neighbors of mine had some
berkshires and they had kids they were
good pigs
and they worked very well for them
berkshires are nice pigs yeah yeah
it's gonna be a completely different
fascination for the kids because
this time around they're not gonna be as
cuddly and as friendly with them i
don't think however well i think you'll
find they will get quite attached to
them jesus well they're charming animals
pigs
ready you don't want to underestimate
the the dangers of getting attached
it's going to happen to you gordon you
might think i'm gone nuts it's going to
happen
absolutely i also want to see how hugh
makes the most out of cooking every last
bit of the pig
this really is nose-to-tail eating right
from the back trotter here in the
tip of this tail to the end of the nose
we use pretty much
everything everything yeah and that's
the excitement of it i mean it's so
versatile
isn't that nice and that that is just a
world away from commercial pork
yeah the color the texture yeah
everything and that will be saying on
the boxes
oh absolutely i thought the ears we
might make
these your special treat today ready
yeah your first job might be to get the
earwax out of the pizza
but isn't it best just to clean his ears
he goes along
god i have to say this is the first you
know that
so gonna send your hair's off now yeah
this is the best tool for the job
[Music]
with the ingredients prepared hugh shows
me his recipe for chinese style pigs
chotters and crispy pig's ears
okay just lift that off this is where
the ears get a bit of an outing on their
own the special treatment just to
celebrate if you like their rather
peculiar but delightful texture do you
cut them up or even yeah i'm going to
cut them into little strips now
right brush them in a bit of mustard and
then press them
nicely into the breadcrumbs
the extremities thank you my goodness
it's all from the head
the head and the truffles amazing how
nice and crispy they are
hmm that is lovely do you think it's
going to be a problem
sending the pigs to the slaughter for
your kids who knows they could get very
attached to the pigs
never stop talking about the food that
you're going to get from them from day
one
from day one make sure you get as much
of that garden
for your pigs as you can negotiate with
your dear wife
getting on for half of it half the
garden certainly a third
the more space they've got the happier
they'll be and you'll have the best
possible pork at the end of it all
it's about half the garden hue christ i
mean tana thinks it's gonna be a little
small pen
your garden will be liquid mud we do me
a favor
cortana yeah sure
we're gonna pull this back now guys yes
yes i want 50 customers all agreeing to
pay for their main course
then we end on a high with a dessert
robert you team up with lawson over
there now
nigel you team up with kevin and work as
a team
now tonight's main course is a
beautifully stuffed satellite served
with pom puree
and caramelised red onions
this has to be one of my favorite cuts
because look you've got a double whammy
you've got two nice eyes of meat and
these beautiful little fillets inside
a very lean meat absolutely delicious
toasted cumin
salt pepper grind
and then just rub it into the lamb cumin
is a really nice way of bringing out the
sweetness of the lamb
and then just mop it up stuffing
apricots that's it ouch
pine nuts again these planters have been
toasted so we're just improving the
flavor every time
salt pepper we're going to bind that
together with a top
of olive oil and it's a really nice
moroccan feel fruity
fresh fragrant stuff it goes down in the
center
there and the smell of those apricots
undertones of humans get extraordinary
fillets and run alongside the stuffing
and just nice and tightly roll that over
just look at that
wrap parma ham you've got this really
nice
marbling of fat running all the way
through there that just gives
the saddle of lamb so much flavor
[Music]
lamb down you lift that up over and roll
pull it nice and tight like make an
amazing big switch roll just twist the
ends
opposite each other in and out in and
out if it's rolled evenly
it's going to cook evenly chill one hour
unwrap tie a loop
around the outside of the lamp loop it
round and then slide it over the lamb
olive oil into the pan
salt pepper and the flavor that cumin
now i can actually smell it
it's absolutely amazing hot oven
40 minutes
[Applause]
it's important to leave the lamb to rest
so it just starts to relax
therefore it becomes a lot more tender
remove string
carve first one through
one slice and look
a beautiful lamb and it smells so sweet
delicious lamb with apricot and cumin
done
back cooking okay robert are we ready
with the lamb tonight i'm serving saute
spinach with pine nuts
chili and garlic creamy mashed potato
and caramelized red onions
this is a really nice thing to do with
onions and it just makes it sort of a
lot more classier
caramelized and it's a really nice way
of having it as a proper vegetable
yes let's go we find the hottest part of
the stove
right taste please taste a little bit of
salt
and just a touch more vinegar in there
yes robert how long for that first table
please
um i'm ready with with mash i'm ready to
caramelize junior
i've just got to do spinach right a
little bit of garlic
half spoon of chili spread that off
nigel are we ready to go with five
how long two minutes five just no no
come on you gotta speed up now nice
that's one table we've got 12 behind so
how long two minutes yeah i mean two
minutes quickly yes yes
let's go then yes right
i want you to come back on this one now
you know that i want you to shine
through this [ __ ]
spinach on a little bit of seasoning yes
just wilt the spinach yes toss the
spinach
yes see how quick you could
just just lighten it up lightly yeah i
don't want it greasy yeah yeah okay
five portions where are the onions good
mashed potatoes
come on i'll show you the first one
let's go
get your [ __ ] hands off my hands
watch
thank you and just follow me so i'm not
asking you to do anything difficult
lawson okay
but just all i want to do right now big
boy yeah is [ __ ] wake you awake a
little bit yes
watch don't sabotage it okay okay right
straighted edge knife watch stay with me
a little bit of seasoning on there a
little bit now that's it good
now watch come on lawson for [ __ ] sake
move
down your [ __ ] donut huh
where's your vinaigrette oh come on
lawson [ __ ] me
you make your [ __ ] snail look fast
move your ass come on
right robert watch now on and then just
glaze
that's how i want it that is beautiful
you're a butcher it's nice and pink yes
one table down 11 to go and that's great
now get a [ __ ] move on yes
go please go table six and lawson
lawson do you think i'm here is your
[ __ ] dusty [ __ ]
hey yeah yeah no bollocks mate move your
ass
all those flavors in this finish were
really good and the stuffing was lovely
the creaminess of the mash i just love
it the tartness of the onions i thought
it was great i'd love to i'd love to
criticize it but i can't it was perfect
my ideal dish
potato and you're scooping it just watch
just watch where's the spinach where's
the onions come on guys
already now let's go where's the spinach
what's all that burnt stuff in there
what did you burn you burnt the chili
all the black bits everything else is
nicely done but the chili's all black
and burns okay chef
yeah kevin get some spinach on
nigel leave him to do that you work on
these plates come on
there's no point in cooking lamb
perfectly making the most amazing mashed
potatoes caramelised onions then we've
got burnt spinach on there nigel
nice yeah chef charlie start again
okay so we came for more from trump
please
hello how was the pasta it was lovely
yes
very nice now you're a serious foodie
yes yeah well i like to think well i'm
serious about food
now everyone would assume you actually
eat like way netter but you're actually
quite fussy eater you don't just scoff
it down you're quite
articulate when it comes to very healthy
the reason why i'm a big girl is because
i drink beer
because i love beer and what's your
favorite beer stella
stella and you get your beer goggles on
do you get in there in a way that you
really seriously it's the only time i've
ever had any sexual satisfaction really
it's when i got the ear problems off no
no
no i mean but i don't drink as much as i
used to obviously when i was younger
yeah i could certainly drink the boys
under the table
now that you've you've made it quite
[ __ ] clear that you hate ponzi food
yeah now in your mind what's the
difference between good honest tasting
food and plenty food
when does it become quantified when
there's about that much of it
and it all looks really pretty but
there's there's a little pile about that
high
and that's it do you think my food's
ponzi well this is my first
taste of your pho when you finally came
back in the [ __ ] restaurant when it
finally arrived at the [ __ ] table
yeah but older how many secrets you
smoke a date
well out there waiting for me food yes
about 20.
thanks bandit normally about 10. what
would make you give up
if i got pregnant which isn't going to
happen now why
because i don't want to get pregnant you
can get pregnant your age you're not
that old
i don't want to get i'll do anything to
make sure you stop smoking you know that
are you going to impregnate me then
i've got a low sperm count out of
service maybe yeah
but what strikes me rather bizarrely is
that all that [ __ ]
smoking you do all day long all the
lager you do all day long
that means in my mind you've got a
[ __ ] palette like a cow's backside
so i want to know how good your palate
is right okay i'm going to test it
you're going to kiss me
not yet put your teeth back in first
i'll give you a kiss after that
later so blindfold this is by a uh
this is quite a moment yeah yeah i've
had this before
see this is quite sexy ready right now
simple test yes right very very simple
test okay
what is it real or processed does it
taste like it's been freshly cooked or
does it taste like it's going out of a
packet
okay so
what is that got no taste whatsoever
so it's soft cheese like a dairy lee or
mm-hmm
have a taste oh no
go on that's the [ __ ] dairy leaf
and the other one was like one of your
fancy cheeses that's got no taste
absolutely right the first one's a
really nice slice of brie and the second
one is [ __ ] dairy lee
right right here we go you'll like this
one
give me your fingers there you go have a
taste
is it proper food or is it processed
food
yeah like a flat bit of
breadcrumb fish or something this one
you like fish
yeah second one's a fish finger
in it which one do you prefer i suppose
the second one
cool [ __ ] hell the first one was a
really nice boujon of soul
and the second one you know the second
one was the [ __ ] phillio fish on
mcdonald's
i really and i hate fillet of fish [ __ ]
you man
i never eat fillet of fish at mcdonald's
i can't bear it right here we go spin it
down with this
which one of these do you prefer oh
steady cool [ __ ] hell
god here we go hey
you got to work tomorrow second one
you like a little tip a special brew
really and what was the second one it
was a [ __ ] quality lag of the second
one
no no a czech lager i prefer the special
bro
and you like the [ __ ] tram's piss
listen mate i'm a cheap
am i saying i can't believe we can take
that off now baby ah
well dear oh dear the special brew that
was the [ __ ] worry
the chance piss i know especially when
you started knocking it back it started
worrying me
i haven't drunk special brew for years
gonna get back to the kitchen all right
mate where's my pudding
pudding's coming stop [ __ ] smoking
stay inside the restaurant
and i'll get your pudding organized all
right great to see you thank you
and stay off the tram's piss yes i know
i couldn't believe that
i'm paying all that money for stella
just get special brew
or tenants
that was without doubt the most
succulent lamb i've ever had i'm not
gonna have another one like that again
probably
when i put glam at home it's okay to be
a little bit pink in the middle but this
is
rare there was blood coming out of it it
was completely
underdone i would have this again and
again and again and it's just
giving me a whole insight how i've been
doing my sunday roast
completely wrong so
gordon ramsay nice to meet you
[Laughter]
okay jean-baptiste results of the main
course yeah please
okay so people who are not happy with
the main course it's nine
altogether nine customers for the main
course yeah
main reason is um undercooked and cold
so a little bit too pink slightly
yeah which is a big difference from the
starter yeah yeah well done
now yeah let's finish it on a high and
you yeah you know
to be honest the deserts are summer
pudding so you can't really [ __ ] that
one yeah there's nothing cooked
okay let's go yes okay yeah
next on the menu i summer pudding with
lime creme fresh
i tried to get two fast food addicts to
kick the junk there's no food in there
it's all beer there's some huh
this is three weeks old just have a wee
smell
yeah be careful you don't get [ __ ]
bitten
and we'll lawson pull it together if you
can do this all on your own hey big boy
tomorrow morning you're gonna wake up
with the biggest hard-on in [ __ ]
birmingham let's go
[Applause]
welcome back to the f word now andrew
griffin is going to take me onto the
first recipe challenge in the series
can she cut it in my kitchen yes i can
move your ass
get in there girl right the rules are
simple the challenger picks
their best dish and i have to try and
beat that with my version
there is one winner of course there's
[Applause]
aren't you
so lasagna lasagna where did you steal
the recipe from my fella actually
seriously yeah what's the secret
ingredient
mixture of beef and lamb have you found
them together yeah
why you just get a little bit of an
extra taste in there i like it in here
yes yeah the first person's ever said
that they're always complaining how hot
it was
i like the heat dude yeah
just sweating off my vegetables putting
in some my pancetta as well
yep putting a bit of oregano now so how
do you get into cooking because you
think very relaxed is very natural in a
professional environment yeah you just
take me into it because i really like it
who got you into it
my mum mainly because not very good at
it
great yeah and so i was kind of making
my own food from when i was very very
young what's the kitchen like at home
what's the kitchen like great although
we're moving house
are you yeah we're moving house and i'm
getting a naga oh no
do you hate argos you're too [ __ ]
young to get a naga no i'm not
that happens when the bus pass comes
janet's drinking portions
don't say that jesus don't because we're
moving out to the country and i'm a bit
like are we giving up on life by moving
out there
you're far too young for an argument i
think yes i started sweating off my
vegetables tomatoes
onions carrots pancetta mushrooms and
garlic
but i'm sweating them off in olive oil
and then adding some red wine
reducing the red wine so it really gives
a nice coat and glaze on the vegetables
you enjoy food a lot yes oh god i bet
there's not a sunday lunch that goes by
that you don't have some form of roast
or something
i'm a mean something else cooker yeah
the most important way of the week would
you not agree
what's sunday sunday lunch yeah
absolutely crucial do you sit down as a
family
yeah i'm friends as well we're very
social we like having our friends around
a lot fantastic that wrist action is
extraordinary my god there's definitely
no lumps in there is that there really
isn't
because i will cry if i have lumps in
this what's the secret ingredient what
do you get
nothing there must be something in there
that's going to make you oh the love of
my hand
passion that's exactly what you say the
discipline rest
and your ambidex as well using both i am
i'm going to say i'm finding that a
little bit harder i'm styling it out
anna
so i'm just going to let my mints cook
out there now and just cut out the right
color
sorry is that the right color it is the
right color what i'm gonna do now is
just put some basil in there ah so you
put your basil in at the end i'm gonna
put the bezel right at the end so it
doesn't go all
sort of you know but i quite like that
does the does the taste not just
soak in if you put it in earlier on oh
do you think it just uh dies
you look [ __ ] sexy with yourself look
at that
[ __ ] [ __ ] hell
are you putting yours together already
yeah of course i am and you're going
about 900 miles an hour no i'm getting
nowhere come on don't over complicate
everything
okay i think you're up last night
practicing until [ __ ] midnight i was
practicing something but it certainly
wasn't cooking
wait get in there
mince over and a really nice generous
dollop of creme fraiche in the mints mix
that in
the last minute and it gives a really
nice richness to the mince
how you doing angel um doing great yeah
ah i love cheese you're enjoying this
do you know what i really am no i
shouldn't be but i really am i can't
believe yours is ready
got some of my cheese mix i've got
absolutely loads my dining it's very
kind but that'll be unfair because if i
win then
you've provided half the recipe
completely flustered
it was all quite jokey before it's
getting a little bit serious now
i really hate having a i'm going to tide
you up now because i can't bear having
another time
god you can't bear mess as well perfect
woman you are you know that
so here she goes
okay right yours is in for 40. yes
mine's going in for 20.
let's see what they look like and tastes
like when they come out the other one
yes okay confident
oh absolutely supremely more confident
you would make a [ __ ] good chef you
know you're so passionate about food i
do love it kid
i've set myself a challenge to get the
nation cooking again this week i've come
up with a curry that even the real life
men behaving badly
can do easily
sunday for us is just basically a day of
slothing we order pizza
open a beer and just veg out for the
whole day
we basically haven't moved on from
university we're still eating extremely
unhealthily
we live in a house with you know there's
five of us and we never eat together
gordon and dave's culinary skills leave
an awful lot to be desired
uh all i ever seem to see the meeting is
takeaway foods
that sort of thing i'm having to live
with both of them and nothing but pizzas
and curries or just like a pain in the
backside
and i think it's about time that they
moved on if we don't make a change i can
imagine us uh still sitting on these
couches in 20 years
single still eating garbage but weighing
like 30 stone and just having the worst
life possible
[Music]
hi guys how are you doing hi gordon
nothing new hi this is
i'm dave nice to meet you good to see
you i am gordon what in the [ __ ] is that
over there
this is toast and patty with curry
flavored super noodles
so tell me about the noodles what have
you done to the you measure out half a
pint
of water and then you put the powdered
sauce on top
what a pile of [ __ ] i don't think i'd
feed that to my pigs you know
i've been in some [ __ ] scary
households in my time but i've never
ever quite come across this from a
chef's point of view um
let alone you know girlfriend position
work
that you should not be eating i swear to
god i mean because that is just
like [ __ ] huh where's the fridge
oh my god what is all that in there
oh [ __ ] hell
guys there's no food in there it's all
beer there's some ham
there's some good for sandwiches well it
was it's because it's three weeks old
just have a wee smell yeah be careful
you don't get [ __ ] bitten
that's that's not great yeah that's
that's high these yogurts are now
four and a half weeks out of date a
freezer pack full of
pizzas yeah chicken nuggets
yeah when you come home at night
do you eat this stuff pissed yeah when
you're just basically anything that's in
the house when we're drunk so we're just
you're [ __ ] disgusting two disgusting
pigs that are [ __ ] hibernating in
clapham
gentlemen the first thing i'm gonna do
yeah before we touch anything else
i want a good [ __ ] clean up
all the stuff that's out of date gordon
yeah i'm going to bring it over
hot noodle pot noodle i think you can
say goodbye to that it's on his last
legs the other mexican chili it's like
an old friend
an old friend yeah get rid of it
[Music]
this little array of takeaway menus is
[ __ ] without them okay because they're
going in there
and they're staying there yeah this is a
good day
now we've cleared out the crap i want to
buy some proper food that still appeals
to the guys
so this is a local parade of shops right
yeah here we go that's one of our
favorites this is one of our favorites
yet
hi guys what's the first thing you smell
in here what do you smell um
spices something that can't go off so
we're thinking of things like turmeric
or mustard seeds and fennel seeds lovely
spices you've got yes
how are you doing oh yeah he does he
does my kebabs
he does your kebabs you serve him kebabs
these people always come for the kebab
sometimes
three times four times a week
that's a me that's a slight over a jack
that's in there four times a week
on top of the pizzas the takeaway
curries maybe we've got some work to do
yeah
right we'll do something simple cool
something that
won't stress you out and something can
be done quicker than ordinary takeaway
a very straightforward easy malaysian
curry we're going to make a curry paste
right okay the most exciting thing about
this paste is that you can make it the
start of the week
yeah use a bit of it and just keep it in
the fridge it's there
yeah ready like butter okay dave i want
you to peel the
ginger gordon i need to cut the chillies
in half garlic
lemongrass and shallots what i'm gonna
do with these ingredients we're not
gonna chop them all
we're just gonna blend them into a paste
bung everything in a blender add
turmeric and blaze
then add a drizzle of ground oil and
blitz again do a little shake
and that's your paste okay i'll smell
that in there
oh well get it all nice and hot yeah and
wash
a little bit in there and start cooking
that out okay
now once we start cooking off this paste
yep then we'll slice the onions put the
onions in
okay just look at the color of that now
no
that's the little magic ingredient in
there now this is what it should be like
a weekend you guys cook you know that
yeah yeah how's it feel to be cooking
i'm actually good really
enjoying it really yeah superb how are
they doing those onions spread them down
nicely sweat no nicely up
see the way it's all starting to break
down yep that's ready now
for the chicken so
don't worry about burning your little
fingers all right yeah on there like
that look
down okay and start sweating
the chicken down so you decide to keep
them on the bodyguard rather than
get them off the reason i'm gonna keep
on the bone okay because it's cooking i
don't want the chicken drying out
coconut milk in please okay take your
time
then add a tin of coconut milk followed
by some stock
spices and soy sauce now
one thing i haven't seen in here is
anything sort of slightly healthy so the
curry's gonna be finished with some
green beans
all right okay we're gonna finish it
with the green beans but hey you can
finish it with spinach you can put
broccoli in there you put cauliflower in
there
but potatoes in there at the end but
you've got to start eating a little bit
[ __ ] healthier yeah
how could you compare that in your
fridge
standing next to that [ __ ] roll of
furry sticky stinky [ __ ] ham
i i'm embarrassed about that i'd be
[ __ ] embarrassed i was embarrassed
at the beginning about that this has
made me even
more embarrassed
[Music]
how's it going here we go look at that
[Music]
for me the most important message yeah
is for you guys to keep it up
because you can slip back into your own
ways no no not at all and you're gonna
have a [ __ ]
potbelly bigger than my [ __ ] picture
about that it's so nice to see you
around the table yeah
yeah guys and stay around the table yeah
yeah let's stay off the [ __ ]
telephone all doing [ __ ]
yeah yeah yeah guys
seriously guys let's do this more often
okay jean-baptiste tickets please wait
five summer putting away please let's go
yeah okay thank you chef
this is a very classic okay summer
dessert yeah yeah
rather than that stodgy white [ __ ]
horrible anemic bread we've got a really
nice tasty brioche okay
right nigel just explain to me yeah work
and talk at the same time tell me what
you're doing quick
right we've um dipped the brioche into a
black currant cooler good we're then
layering it
with fresh strawberries another brioche
in the cauli yeah we've been layering it
with black currants blueberries
and then we'll be uh served with a creme
fraiche with a lime zest
good good good good let's go lawson if
there's anyone
yeah in this country tonight that could
set fire to that it would be you
okay stay off the [ __ ] stove
let's go five
right raspberry jam good raspberry bad
like i've done and always hit the center
of the plate yes
and then with a [ __ ] watch just on the
top one there
and then a little bit just a little bit
but don't don't don't [ __ ] the plates up
yeah nice and gentle watch
a little bit there and round
i asked you to hit the middle of the
[ __ ] plate look where yours is cuddle
curry oh come on
sorry i mean i can't lose i can't keep
on staying there okay in the middle
come on kevin let's go i'm ready you're
ready why are your plates always so
dirty
[ __ ] it now robert
you get a hot spoon and it's called a
quinnell
watch so you get a hot spoon like that
it just melts the cream
don't get too hot otherwise it [ __ ]
slides off off
and then on yeah no [ __ ] off you do it
yourself cool dear
service please
presentation was great it looked like it
was going to be really fantastic
but it was just a bit too acidic i
actually thought that was really nice
really really nice that's the best out
of the three i think
this last table okay i want you to do
from start to finish
and [ __ ] finish on a high for me
three summer puddings away let's go big
boy yes
okay then yeah good man okay [ __ ] me on
good grasp is on
there get everyone looking like that and
we're going to end on a [ __ ] hike
robert off you go yeah let's go
make it work lawson you owe this one to
yourself let's go now lawson
if you can do this all on your own hey
big boy tomorrow morning we'll wake up
with the biggest hard-on in [ __ ]
birmingham let's go
okay good nice two seconds go yes yeah
that's fine don't worry they've got an
extra bonus go yes
service please okay double seven yeah
quickly uh lawson they look [ __ ]
beautiful so far so don't [ __ ] it up
please yes
lawson can you hear me in there yeah is
there anything in there between those
ears come on yeah yeah
service please i can't do it
nice well done start clearing down [ __ ]
me
okay you pulled that back there yeah yes
yeah yeah
i feel like i let me team down when i
first don't worry about that we got
there in the end you hit me in the face
yeah yeah stay at it yeah i'm going to
keep working at it yeah i'm not going to
bottle out
that last table was fantastic yeah well
done
good boy all right cheers
next on the menu is judgement time in
the recipe challenge
very very close very close yeah but um
the winner for today is yes the brigade
finds out what the diners really thought
of their food
they're taking the piss some people
absolutely [ __ ] anything
and it's time to christen the pigs i
want you to start thinking about some
names either way okay
trinity and susannah everyone's got a
flat out someone's got small nipples
welcome back to the f word now she's
calm and confident but will the blind
takes us prefer her dish
over mine ready come on then kid
get in there hello
hi hello okay so we're going to start
with the red dish
quite strong strong flavor strong
mushrooms the muffins are very rare but
i probably could eat about
half
quite light carrot nice yeah nice the
meat and the vegetables
that's really nice it's quite hard
yeah and first of all of course for me
is the most important i like to get off
to a good start
okay right very close once again very
very close
very close yeah but um the winner for
today is yes
welcome no really
they find yours too rich too rich yeah
no don't look so [ __ ] smart
then you maybe have a job tomorrow okay
come on oh you can cut down the kitchen
we'll do me a favor yeah
[ __ ] off yes thank you my dolly thank
you cool dear
great jesus christ
time for a bit of sanity here are the
pigs come on guys
let's go quick jack come here quick hold
on are we getting pigs
right how much space do you think they
need
lots of space is that enough room you're
the little pig legally a pig pen needs
to be no smaller than the length of the
pig
but i'm following hugh's advice and
giving them a whopping 70 square meters
for the pigs is that enough space for
the pigs yeah
now listen you know they're gonna be
sleeping out here okay and they're gonna
be getting nice and fat
okay and once you get nice and fat guess
what we'll do to them
eat that yeah we're gonna have the most
amazing bacon sandwich
stop there
look how much room they've got so i can
see tana's face thinking this is my
this is my garden it was looking very
pretty and very lovely
um but golden's very persuasive the only
way to get this into the ground is
actually think it's anti-war thompson's
head
the pig pen is nearly ready so we're off
to see top berkshire breeders
christine and kevin to bring home the
bacon look at that
they are beautiful these are rare unique
and
the flavor of these things are
extraordinary oh these are fantastic
pork pigs
do you want to see some little ones i'd
love to see the little ones come on
let's see some little ones we bring them
in
look at this there you go
wow two days old lily megan you're
attached to that one already aren't you
dear oh dear oh dear hello
you are a very luscious bacon sandwich
now look at you
look at them they're beautiful they're
very cute aren't they
the berkshire pig would be a good choice
of pig for gordon because
it is that little bit smaller but the
berkshire is a particularly friendly pig
and you can feel safe to have it around
children
we won't be taking these little piggies
home they need to stay with their mother
until they're eight weeks old
now we have to decide which two we're
going to have
i want to serve pork as the final meal
of the series so working backwards from
the optimum slaughtering age
christine has recommended two 12-week
old girls
now you need to think about when you
want to send these pigs off to the
butcher you don't want it over fat pig
no
no no no but you need nice rounded
bottoms
yes this one here the you know two to
two yeah that's nice
that one and that one yes shall we yeah
do you put them in the back
[Music]
right tony i'll get the um where's the
board watch out guys
let's go guys
here we go
[Applause]
it has to be the perfect way from a
chess point of view to start with a raw
ingredient
nurse it wow then eat it you can't get
any better than that
why don't you start thinking about some
names either way okay daddy that's it
trini and susannah hello everyone's got
a fat ass someone's got small nipples
okay miss you yeah two seconds nigel
let's go
okay okay the reason for the desserts
are 13 people
refuse to pay for the desserts 13. yeah
what he said is too acidic to acid yeah
and
water juicy over juicy
[ __ ] it now they're taking a place some
people moan about absolutely [ __ ]
anything
sixteen diners refuse to pay for their
starters nine refuse to pay for the main
and 13 didn't pay for the pudding so of
the 150 plates of food
served only 112 were paid for
it started off slightly shaky and for a
bunch of amateurs
to come into this kitchen tonight and
then pull it back through the main
hats off and nigella thank you promise
me you'll stick to butchery
yeah yeah well yeah don't get a
restaurant
okay thanks [ __ ] good to see you
smiling because i'll tell you what for a
small guy who got a big pair of bollocks